au lendement de la mobilisation
nationale marquée par moins de
participation quelques actions ciblées
ont été menées ce vendredi à paris les
employés du musée du louvre ont bloqué
l'accès à la pyramide rassemblés en
chantant ils ont revendiqué leur droit
et leur désaccord avec le projet de
réforme des retraites du gouvernement
autre action dans la capitale au siège
de la cfdt selon le syndicat réformiste
des dizaines d'individus se sont
introduits violemment au siège des
grévistes qui reproche notamment aux
syndicats de plier devant les
propositions du gouvernement
en province les avocats aussi ont
manifesté en chanson sur les marches du
palais de justice de bordeaux à
l'occasion de l'audience solennelle de
la rentrée à caen c'est en observant une
minute de silence que les avocats ont
protesté
ils dénoncent tous la réforme de leur
caisse de retraite
autonome et autofinancée nous en avons
assez d'être méprisés par le garde des
sceaux par les pouvoirs publics et nous
tiendrons bon jusqu'au bout
nous bloquerons le système jusqu'au bout
le garde des sceaux nous a adressé le 14
janvier une fin de non recevoir
nous n'avons aucune réponse sur notre
revendications légitimes et surtout la
question du doublement de nos
cotisations et concomitamment de la
diminution de notre retraite de 1400
euros à 1000 euros n'est pas réglé non
pas de réponse donc continuons à bloquer
le service public de la justice plus que
jamais à traces bourg pas de réforme des
retraites mais un ras-le-bol général de
la part des soldats du feu ils étaient
un millier de sapeurs pompiers à
protester contre les agressions dont ils
font l'objet
lors de leur intervention aujourd'hui on
est là pour montrer notre notre
ras-le-bol notre dégoût notre
incompréhension face à ces agressions
et aujourd'hui on est là pour avoir le
soutien de la population
le soutien de nos autorités et
faire en sorte que
que tout ça change on demande à ce que
pour certains types d'interventions dans
certains endroits qu'on sait sensible on
puisse être accompagné systématiquement
par les forces de l'ordre alors pour
manifester contre les violences qui ont
eu lieu et qui auront certainement
encore lieu
malheureusement en alsace et partout
ailleurs d'ailleurs des manifestations
quotidiennes qui prouve que malgré
l'essoufflement la situation sociale
n'est toujours pas apaisées une nouvelle
journée d'action nationale contre la
réforme des retraites est prévue le 24
janvier prochain
[Musique]